all right let's talk about this news
from the post-millennial breaking
classified documents from Biden's time
as VP discovered in his UPenn office
whoa whoa whoa classified documents we
heard that Donald Trump had classified
documents and they were the FBI raided
his house all right wow I mean the FBI
is going to have to raid uh Joe Biden
yeah right I do not believe for a second
the FBI rated his house looking for
classified doctors I think it was just a
fishing Expedition oh I agree for sure
but they're not going to rate Joe Biden
at all for any reason so you know in his
defense he probably just forgot to do it
though
but it's a vegetable no but for real
like he probably just forgot they were
there yeah like even even if Trump had
classified documents it's probably just
absent-minded it's like we grabbed a box
we carried it out we were moving out
they turned it into a federal case
Chicago attorney has been assigned by
U.S attorney general Merrick Garland to
review classified documents found at the
Penn Biden Center for diplomacy and
Global engagement in Washington reports
CBS News it relates to about 10
documents from Biden's vice presidential
office now see I I isn't it that's
that's like that's disqualifying as as a
public office isn't it like that's at
least it so statistically speaking has
been in his office at least six years at
least six or something longer yeah
probably longer yeah he's the forgetful
guy I mean it happens right you lose a
paper there and there and then you know
you press the red button and holy cow we
have nuclear world but that's a whole
other subject to get into another
interesting fact about what we're seeing
being reported today was that these
documents were actually found uh a day
before the midterm elections and we're
hearing about it right now this is the
doj is also considering pressing charges
against Donald Trump for of course
having his classified documents Donald
Trump by the way just sent out a message
to everyone on Truth social saying quote
when is the FBI going to raid the many
homes of Joe Biden perhaps even the
White House probably not anytime soon
since of course the FBI pretty much is
working as the own private Stasi of the
White House and uh essentially being
very busy Banning people especially on
social media for their speech that they
disagreed with so I don't see that
happening anytime soon I don't know what
you guys think that'd be like a scene
out of South Park if they rented the
White House yeah yeah they should I mean
look why not they shouldn't I'll I'll be
honest going after Donald Trump was
wrong yeah writing him over this is a
total BS yeah but if this is the
standard that the Democrats and the FBI
want to play by then uh we expect Joe
Biden to get right I mean this is this
from when he was vice president
so that calls into question eligibility
if they want to play this game that it's
illegal to take classified documents
like they did for Trump and they wanted
to argue that it disqualified him for
running again remember this right
they're putting out those memes where
they were like Trump can't run for
president now that he's been uh caught
with these documents oh this is an
interesting thing about Joe Biden there
you're saying huh yeah but that always
kind of happens I mean if they didn't do
anything for Hillary Clinton's private
email server they're not going to do
anything here I mean it's pretty clear
it's pretty obvious I mean what else do
you expect the FBI to do yeah it should
be obviously anybody with a brain that
they treat conservatives Republicans
totally different than what they do to
liberals so obvious double standard
nobody wants to point it out especially
on the left well yeah but so what do you
guys say to people like your friends and
your family when they don't believe you
when you look when you you show them a
story like this like here's the FBI
rating Trump's home yeah here's Sam
saying nothing's going out with Joe
Biden like how do you well I know but I
just don't even have that conversation
yeah because you're like yeah during
Christmas I'm uh that's the best time to
have those conversations it was it was
my father-in-law and he's like he's like
um he brought up Trump he said man that
guy Trump he's like Hitler I was like
what
I was like you said did you see what
they did at the capital it was crazy
that's like
bruh but um
how did you counter how did that
conversation go I was just nice about it
because English is not his first
language my wife is from uh Jalisco Mako
he's a real nice guys just that uh I
think people don't understand that the
typical American that's not into
politics when they turn on the news they
just believe it that guy's is in a suit
he's uh he's a journalist he's not gonna
lie to me you know what I mean so a lot
of people fall for it so I just told him
I said he's not a bad guy he might be an
[ __ ] but he's not a bad guy he's not
Hiller I was like do you know what
Hitler did yeah but this is a scary
thing that I've been talking about all
day it's like we have to have
conversations and try to bring regular
people like that into understanding
otherwise we're gonna see kids they're
growing up and they're not hearing these
ideas at all these kids are going to get
older and they're they're the only thing
they're going to know is wokeness
there's not going to be an argument
their whole world of view is built upon
one idea because the other conversation
is not happening yeah but so many people
in this country is Out Of Tune with
politics they don't vote yeah they don't
I mean they get a glimpse here and there
like how many people actually voted in
this past election
in my country it's what was it like 58
or 60 it was actually pretty high
relatively like more and more people are
getting politically active which is a
good thing I think which is great but
it's like 40 percent of these countries
just they're just tuned out they don't
yeah no uh journalist last election
during uh you know when Bob won the
presidency
um he had some counties that actually
was pretty hot they said like a hundred
percent of the people turned out to vote
some places more than a hundred yeah you
know that's crazy that's amazing they
were saying I guess that because of
covid people moved and that caused a
shock to the system where like more than
a hundred percent of registered voters
are turning up but I'm not you know it's
funny
what happened Joe Biden's a superstar
man yeah 81 million votes and he'd even
campaign yeah he was he was in the
basement the whole time yeah he wasn't
showing up I don't think we can beat him
the next election yeah well no but
here's how can you here's the thing
about that we were talking about before
the show about like Revenue viewership
and everything in 2020 the eye the
pandemic made everything very very weird
so I think I think one of Biden's
biggest advantages was he didn't need to
campaign because it was a culture war
and they forced everybody into it they
took away your movies you can go to
movies you can go to sporting events you
couldn't even leave your house and they
told you it was Donald Trump's fault
then they had to do a mail-in ballot
yeah so being in the basement was
relatable to a lot of people right
you know he's staying there
I think Hunter helped him a lot too he's
famous yeah yeah a lot of photos a lot
of videos of that guy he's a great
Summit of verite artist and uh he also
started a YouTube channel
what was like his girlfriend or his wife
would throw a gun in a garbage can and
get in trouble yeah yeah like wow
right in your school yeah who could have
drugs and a gun and nothing happens to
you you can't be black that's what I
call Freedom that's the American dream
is that the constitution should be based
on why don't you call white proof
there you go but if it existed yo I got
to be honest I I kind of would love to
watch a hunter Biden YouTube channel
yeah could you imagine do you keep
vlogging every day two subscribers in a
week in a week yeah yeah he's at a club
his shirt's off and he's just like
shaking he's got white powder across it
to his face people are gonna be like
this is awesome like try to do something
now punch try to arrest me now it's like
how he goes legitimate is that he
creates a YouTube channel around his
Antics and then doesn't need to take
corrupt money from foreign businesses or
anything like that you know but give him
any ideas man I mean no but I I would
watch it yeah I would subscribe yeah
click the notification button actually
right out of this whole show form I mean
look Hunter Biden doing YouTube videos
means he's not doing corrupt business
deals I'll take it you know and we'll
have a good time we'll laugh what's this
educational background I know he got
kicked out of military for for drugs I
think I'm not sure what his education
background is he's had some very
significant jobs that people would die
for yeah like he was uh on the a board a
board member of barisma an energy
company in Ukraine don't even speak the
language
Mexico I don't speak any Spanish and I'm
over I'm on the board of an energy
company you don't speak a lick of
Spanish a black guy
but like actually think about it they're
going to be sitting there in a meeting
and they're all gonna be speaking
Spanish and you're gonna be like okay
see
and then uh and then your your dad shows
up and uh demands the president fire a
prosecutor who's investigating your
company it's on tape
they're bragging about it you know
what's crazy they've been investigating
Trump ever since even before he became
president they've been investing at gate
net man every day of the year for like
the last five six years can we just
investigate Biden for one day just one
day spend like fifty dollars I think I
think they're talking about doing
something not not gonna necessarily
trust McCarthy and the rest of the
Republicans but they're talking about
the I think Jim Jordan's doing heading
up a committee on the weaponization of
government right yeah so you know
fingers crossed I don't know how much
which is a real a thing oh yeah yeah I
mean the one thing we talk about all the
time is that a bunch of pro-lifers got
arrested by the feds for being at
abortion clinics but the protesters
protesters who show up to Kavanaugh and
Amy Connie Barrett's house no problem
even though it's like well come on like
where's there's there's no no it's just
it's com it's it's completely lopsided I
mean you mentioned it earlier yeah yeah
it is a government is like so corrupt
it's like it's not even yeah I used to
thought our country was like I mean our
country is better than most I think it's
the best country we travel all over you
although we're Australia London I mean
it's no more it's no and we got so many
more opportunities I mean like we went
to Australia London they're talking
about U.S politics 24 7. yeah that's
weird they're talking about Trump in
Australia that's weird yeah yeah and we
went to Canada man the ladies just we
had a comedy show she was probably from
head to toe yeah it's like everything in
the world evolves around the United
States of America yeah a lot of people
want to be here too yeah oh yeah have
you had a check out the uh Southern
border that's right everybody yeah the
crazy thing about that is you get people
coming from Africa they'll fly from
Africa to Brazil and then take trains
and convoys up to the United States
border yeah and then you get the left
acting like it's you know just refugees
I'm like bro they had like six thousand
dollars to do that yeah yeah that's a
lot of money yeah yeah somebody's
financing that I don't
how did some dude who lives in Western
Africa yeah save up three grand per
person yeah to fly to Brazil yeah then
take this trip up and pay the pay the
Smugglers and the traffickers
it's crazy it's a system set up yeah I'm
sure as hell not walking 3 000 miles
like they make it out to me yeah it did
not work they run on top of trains and
stuff yeah that's like walking from here
that's like walking from Virginia to
California that's 2 000 miles yeah they
saying they walk in 3 000 miles there's
no way yeah
so what do we do
meditate that helps me yeah it helps you
kind of like be okay with it I guess you
know what I mean like you yeah but also
when the rubber hits the road if the
wheels are spinning too fast it's just
you get no traction so it's good to kind
of reorient and realize that life is
actually pretty good regardless of the
chaos yeah we still have a goodness kind
of the state of the best country in the
world we could be doing so much better
though but yeah well that just can't be
cruises I guess thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time